네 안녕하세요 이번에 꼬마빌딩 스터디
32위를 모집합니다 최근에 빌딩
거래량이 좀 많이 올라가고 있는데
요즘에 좀 빌딩 관심들이 좀 많이
생기신 거 같아요 저희 스터디 같은
경우에는 2016년도에 처음 시작을
해서 8년째 이어오고 있는 그런
스터디 강입니다 제가 자부하는데 정말
업계에서 제일 오래되고 제일 유익한
강의라고 좀 생각이 들고 10000명
정도 수강생분이 계셨는데 한 200분
정도 건물주가 되었습니다 그 정도로
되게 검증된 강의라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다데 그래서 6월 15일부터
2시부터는 진행이 되고 저는 1주
차와 5주차를 맡아서 강의를 진행할
예정입니다 통계자료 분석과 앞으로
빌딩 투자를 어떻게 해야 되는지
그리고 어떤 거를 조심해야 되는지
위주로 좀 강의를 하고 그리고 성공
사례뿐만 아니라 실패 사례를 좀 많이
다룰 예정이에요 제가 유튜브에는 사실
실패 사례를 말씀 못 드리는데 강의를
통해서 실패 사례를 많이 말씀드릴 수
있을 것 같습니다 그리고 이제 빌딩
매입하고 난 뒤에 관리에 대한 부분도
다룰 예정이니까 기대하셔도 좋을 것
같습니다 그리고이 강의를 통해서 빌딩
정보뿐만 아니라 터디 수강생분들끼리
이런 네트워크 그리고 이제 저희가
건축사 님이랑 시공사 대표님 그리고
은행 지점장님을 만날 일이 없잖아요
근데이 강의를 통해서 그런 전문가들과
함께 한 팀을 이룰 수 있는 기회라고
저는 생각을 합니다네 안녕하세요 양
회사입니다 저는 빌사남 빌스 세무
파트를 담당하고 있고 저는 비상한
고비스 4기부터 강의를 하고 있습니다
뭐 맡고 있는 주제는 세법 강의라고
생각하시는데요 정확히는 사실 세법의
이야기는 한 20% 정도밖에 안 되는
거 같고요 부동산 법인을 설립하는
과정 그리고 설립을 했으면 운영하는
과정 그리고 나중에 자금을 회수하는
과정까지 세금에 대한 이야기라기보다는
부동산 설립 전반에 관한 이야기라고
생각하시면 될 거 같습니다 저는 건축
설계를 담당하고 있는 건축사로서 약
70여 의 그런 신축과 리모델링
프로젝트를 진행해 왔습니다 이런 많은
경험을 바탕으로 여러분들께 상세하게
어 실제 어떤 식으로 설계가 되고
공사가 되는지 현장감 있는 내용들을
전달해 드릴 수 있을 것 같습니다
그리고 저희가 강의하기 전에 저희가
설계했던 현장을 직접 방문해서 제가
이제 하나부터 열까지 현장에 있었던
이러 이슈들을 설명해 드리고 있는데이
사례들의 눈으로 보시는 것뿐만이
아니라 직접 현장에서 체험하시면서
더생각 세하게 현장감을 느끼실 수
있으실 것 같습니다 성공적인 빌딩
투자를 원하신다면 bsn 스터디가
답입니다 저희 bsn 스터디에서는
건축의 기본적인
법규부가 마지막 준공까지 시공에
관련된 내용에 대해서 예비 건축주
분들한테 설명을 드리고요 그리고
마지막으로는 시공비에 대한 이슈
신축과 리모델링의 장단점으로 내
건물이 신축이나 리모델링이 어떤게
적정하지 한눈에 파악할 수 있게
저희가 스터디에서 설명을 해드리니까
이번 스터디에서 오셔서 직접 확인해
보시면 좋을 것 같습니다 그래서
우리를 통해서 매입하지 않더라도 이런
전문가들의 조언을 통해서 빌딩
투자하는데 있어서 도움이 될 수 있을
거라고 저는 생각이 됩니다 그
여러분들이 빌딩 투자하실
계획이시라면이 강의를 들으시면 반드시
도움이 되실 거라고 생각이 듭니다
비스를 돕게 된 계기가 어떻게 되세요
지금 사업체 하나 운영하고 있는데
언젠가는 제 건물에서 한번 사업체를
운영해 보고 싶어서 관심을 받고
었습니다 유튜브에서
알고리듬 바로 알게 되는데 동지의
주변 지인 추천도 있었어 가지고 또
연치 않게 했습니다 유튜브를 통해서
알게 됐고요 한 6개월 전에 저희
딸이 치과를 강남역 쪽으로 다녔는데
그때 배 갖고 한번 꼭 뵙고 싶어서
꼭 입문을 하게 됐습니다 건물주
강의가 많은데 불쌍함을 선택한 이유가
뭘까요 유튜브 봤던 것 중에 연남동
케이스가 있었는데 감면 기게 저한테
다가와서 좋았습니다 일단은 대표님
인생이 너무 좋으시고요 사실 이제
유튜브에 여러 강의들이 있고 법인들이
있는데 왠지 믿음도 좀 갖고 실제
강의를 들어보니까 무조건 이렇게
투자하면 돈 크게 벌 수 있다 이게
아니라 장단점이 리스크에 대한 부분도
알려주시는 부분들이 유튜브에도 좀
느껴가고 그래서 보겠습니다 일단 또
김윤수 대표님 믿음이 가서 신청을
하게 됐습니다 강의 내용은 어떠셨어요
어 아까 말씀드린 것처럼 이렇게 해서
이렇게 하면 뭐 돈을 크게 벌 수
있어요 단기간에 성공할 수 있어요
이런 관점이 아니라 실제적으로 뭐
리스크에 대한 부분들도 굉장히 알려
주셨고 유튜브에서는 절대 알 수 없는
디테일한 부분들을 좀 알 수 있어서
너무 좋았고요 중개 법인만이 아니라
이제 건축이나 이런 부분까지 시공사도
대표님도 오시고 이러다 보니까 토타
시 같은 그런 느낌이 있어서 되게
좋았습니다 내 주차별로 다른 내용으로
강사님께서 알려주셨는데 굉장히 쉽게
다가오게 해주셔서 너무 좋았습니다
임장을 이렇게 다녀봤는데 저희가 이제
대치동 같은데 예를 들때면
2017년도부터 대로변 쪽으로 좀
이렇게 건물들이 들었었는데 지금
이면도로 안까지 들어 쓰고 있는 걸네
느낄 수가 있었습니다 앞으로의 목표는
어떻게 될까요 어 뭐 언젠가는네 제
건물 에서 뭐 비즈니스를 해보고
싶기는 하네요 5년에서 7년 사이에
합 50억에서 100억에 되는
건물주가 되는게 저의 망입니다
[음악]